I am live uh is this thing on I can't
even tell I think it is I'll wait a few
seconds for people to connect I'm going
to be talking about that bizarre press
conference that Donald Trump gave one of
the strangest things that I have seen in
a while uh absolutely bizarre press
conference I would call it a gong show
I'm going to be talking about that also
will be talking about tomorrow's show
going to talk about some show changes
that are going on all of that type of
stuff so I hope that you will I hope the
connection holds out number one because
it's been a little bit nuts lately every
time I've tried to do a live stream and
I also hope that we don't get trolled
too badly in the comments I mean we're
gonna get trolled obviously but but
hopefully won't be too too bad uh okay
so Donald Trump did this insane oh and
I'll mentioned by the way also uh live
shout outs and thank yous to anybody who
signs up for membership during the live
stream and in fact jack Webster just did
I have no idea if it's coincidence we've
only been on the live stream for a
minute and 13 seconds but that being
said big shout-out to Jack Webster uh
you can sign up david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code i voted 17 so I
was watching this Trump press conference
earlier I've never really seen anything
like it the most interesting part to me
was obvious obviously other than just
Donald Trump's and generally bizarre
nature and the I don't know if it's ADHD
or what it is that that's going on with
Trump but something very very strange is
going on that's undeniable that's always
interesting but there was this exchange
with cNN's Jim Acosta where Trump almost
gave like what not that Donald Donald
Trump can really lecture but he gave a
sort of lecture about what fake news is
and why he thinks that CNN is fake news
and saying it's very fake news and blah
blah blah it was so odd in that Trump he
almost kept in
interrupting himself during this press
conference to make I don't even know
that you would call them jokes I guess
maybe you would call them jokes but very
strange sort of comments and uh
everything about it was bizarre when it
would cut to Jim Acosta you would see
Sean Spicer in the background holding it
looked like a stack of books and
notebooks and making notes what I would
give to see what those notes are right
when Trump is dressing down a reporter
for being very fake news what could Sean
Spicer possibly be writing down there oh
yeah uh I'll also insult Jim Acosta when
I do my press conference or something
like that I have no idea I mean just
very very strange and bizarre uh so that
that's number one number two there's no
real answers to anything from Trump
during the press conference and there's
a user on our reddit discussion forum
who put together a really really good
post um and I apologize I don't have it
in front of me who it was but basically
it was a list of all of the stuff that
Donald Trump claimed as accomplishments
during the UH prep dirt during the press
conference as things that he's done so
far and I think what I might do on on
our next show is sort of breakdown that
most of those aren't really
accomplishments I did a segment
yesterday on the show where I said
Donald Trump hasn't actually
accomplished anything mostly it's been
executive orders the biggest one of
course the muslim-majority country
immigration ban which is gone I mean it
just it's been undone already by courts
and beyond that it's been suggestions
and that type of thing um okay i don't
know if i should go uh horizontal people
are angry about vertical video I'm split
on this because if I move my camera to
horizontal before continuing I don't
know what that's going to do posted by
gloom skull by the way yes one of our
moderators on the reddit discussion
forum I'm gonna try to go a horizontal
here and uh I apologize in advance if
this makes anybody dizzy or cut causes
new problems let's take a look here okay
I have rotated the device let's see if
that works now are we horizontal no we
are not hmm it looks like we're going
from bad to worse uh yeah hmm ok so do I
disconnect and start over I mean that's
really the option at this point or do we
just go back to vertical you know what
we're going back to vertical because I
don't want to disconnect and lose
everybody who's on with us right now ok
so we're just going to deal with it I
guess you can't you can't rotate while
we are live and and for that I sincerely
sincerely apologize um ok for people
with this enactment start over in a
second